Target Universe was a victim of the MGM
bankruptcy poor ratings and multiple
other factors the point is we never got
a conclusion to Stargate Universe we
never found out what's what would happen
to the crew of Destiny what the mission
was and they never came home today I
thought with the possibility of Stargate
returning in the future it'd be
interesting to explore some of the ideas
that circulate the internet around how
they could potentially save the crew to
Destiny how they could bring those
people back
so with all that being said welcome to
side Trek your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
foreign
[Music]
the most obvious way to get the crew of
Destiny home is to somehow have some
sort of ship reach Destiny and that is
something that I have postulated before
I have brought that idea to the
Forefront however it is a very difficult
thing to do now they do know where
Destiny is they can relay that
information back that's not a problem
and that's something a lot of people
tend to forget they seem to think that
because Destiny will set off millions of
years ago that it's going to be really
really far away but in reality although
it's halfway across the universe
with the hyperdrive engines that exist
in Stargate you could actually more than
likely reach them within a few months
that is actually possible especially
with the Asgard hyperdrives because we
know that they could travel from the Ida
galaxy to the Milky Way in a matter of
hours whereas it takes us to Atari two
weeks to get from milk away to Pegasus
now that the Towery have the Asgard
knowledge the database maybe we've
created some sort of hyperdrive
hybrid that can actually travel between
galaxies really really quickly now that
doesn't mean that it's going to be a
straight three month John all the way to
Destiny they're gonna have to stop for
to refuel they're gonna have to stop to
get supplies and there's going to be
things that mean it's not going to be
that easy however they've had 10 years
and that is definitely a possibility
maybe they could just travel there by
ship pick them up
and whoever wants to stay can stay
whoever wants to leave can leave and
that is a distinct possibility
the second theory I've seen online
quite a lot is uh using a black hole now
this could potentially work
um but I think people are getting it a
little bit wrong the idea is that I've
seen postulated would be that the people
in the Milky Way galaxy use a black hole
to dial Destiny and then send a team to
rescue them now the problem with that
is although a a black hole yes it more
than likely can power the gate and yes
it can keep it open for a really long
time actually indefinitely
um enough time in fact to get people to
Destiny I don't think that's the issue
the problem is gate travel is only one
way
so if they were to use a black hole in
order to establish a wormhole from
somewhere in the Milky Way or Pegasus to
Destiny that Wormhole would only be from
there to Destiny and it would never
bring the people of Destiny home
the problem is
Destiny doesn't have enough power to
dial Earth now there are some other ways
that I think could possibly work which
tie into
Stargate Atlantis and Stargate sg1 now
now Samantha Carter and Rodney McKay
created The Carter McKay Bridge which is
essentially a macro sequence which is
uploaded to the Stargate Network
and essentially it dials the dials
Stargates in order transmits the data
dials on X1 transmits the data until it
reaches its final destination now there
would need to be a hell of a lot of
calculation involved in in order to get
this working because it's not just
traveling between two galaxies in fact
you're going to be traveling between 30
40 50 hundreds in fact of galaxies
because Destiny left millions of years
ago and although it's only traveling
um
slightly faster than light
it still has traveled pretty far so a
possibility is that McKay and Carter
both develop a program that they can
upload to this target Network so they
can
hop between the Stargates that were
placed by the Sea chips in between Earth
and Destiny
in order to make the connection now the
only problem is Destiny is constantly
moving and if they can figure out a way
of stopping Destiny like indefinitely
stopping Destiny in close range of a
predetermined planet for example this
could work
the only problem I can see is maybe they
need to do something to the Stargates on
each planet which is going to make the
mission
hell of a lot longer but there has been
10 years in between so maybe they've
already got started they've done a good
portion of it and it's going to be the
final steps when we next see Stargate
now this is another theory that I came
up with on my own and I don't think
anyone else has come up with this idea
um but I think it's an interesting one
especially since we now have the Asgard
core and their technology
so we all know that the Asgard are
essentially a clone race they that the
entire reason that they're now extinct
is because they were copies of copies of
copies and they had genetic degradation
which meant they couldn't reproduce
naturally anymore but the underlying
principle is that they had mastered
cloning so if one of them died they
could re-upload their Consciousness to a
new body and they could survive
now that we have this technology now
that we have all of their knowledge and
having had 10 years in the past to
explore that knowledge
could it not be possible
using the chair in Destiny
to somehow
transfer the consciousness
through the gate kind of like a radio
wave so it's only data being transferred
it's not actually physical matter being
transferred so they could dial
Earth could dial Destiny and they could
Destiny could then basically
sent transmit the data across the way
that they would get the data into
Destiny would be by sitting into that
chair which basically uploads your
Consciousness to Destiny and then they
could use the technology that they have
from the Asgard to clone the bodies of
the people who were on Destiny and
re-upload their Consciousness to a body
that is situated within the Milky Way
galaxy this is slightly slightly a
little bit of a cop-out because it means
that the original bodies are going to be
drifting in in space and they're going
to be dead essentially they're going to
be dead but their Consciousness and
everything about them will have been
transferred to a clone body and they
will for all intents and purposes be
home
this is a
idea that I've had and it it kind of
works within Stargate knowing that we've
got this technology from the Ascot now
we we will have learned a hell of a lot
from the Asgard core given the 10 years
that's passed and we know that the
Asgard had this technology to clone
people and transfer Consciousness from
one vessel to another
so is it not possible is it not feasible
to assume that they're gonna at least
attempt it
maybe this could be a way to bring back
again
maybe it could be a way to bring back uh
the scientist who was
uh in her actual body she was disabled
but she took over again's body and
obviously they both ended up dying but
they
now reside within the ship could they
not return by getting a new body because
the actor the actresses are perfectly
hateful it was literally a plot device
that the the scientist was disabled and
she
she basically transferred into gin's
body just so she could help on Destiny
but she liked being able to walk and
talk and she wasn't disabled anymore
this could be a really interesting story
I could bring up a lot of ethical
questions about whether or not it's
a good a good use of technology to
transfer someone from a disabled body
into a perfectly abled body
but it's also a really good way to save
the crew of Destiny yes it's kind of a
cop-out like I've said because for all
in terms of purposes they will be dead
but
could it work it's an idea that I've had
floating around my mind for a little
while and there are bound to be plot
holes in it they're about to be things
in the theory that just don't work but
maybe if we work at it it could be
something that could work and if anyone
at Amazon MGM penguin or parker whoever
is going to be developing Stargate if
you like the idea you're perfectly okay
to take it and
work with it because I think it could
work I think it's something that is
interesting enough to work and then it
poses those moral dilemmas of did we
actually save them or did we just create
a new version of them
and then there's the whole the whole
dilemma that gets associated with that
which makes great sci-fi in my opinion
but what do you think out of all the
theories that I've just mentioned what
would be your favorite what would be the
best way to save the crew of Destiny or
do you have a completely different idea
altogether let me know in the comment
section down below and whilst you're
there hit like And subscribe and press
the Bell notification so you don't miss
a single video also consider becoming a
fully first side tracker by joining our
patreon patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack thank you so much for watching
my name's Matt and I'll see you
next week
[Music]